36 year old divorced grandmother and
Republican congresswoman Lauren bobert
appeared on a panel yesterday
Congressional hearing about the high
cost of prescription drugs an important
issue and she declared during this
hearing that the reason she had a third
child is because birth control was too
expensive so she opted to leave the
pharmacy without paying for the
prescription I guess having unprotected
sex leading to this third child that she
ultimately had now there are factual
inaccuracies here there are moral
conundrums here let's listen to the clip
first and then we're going to discuss it
Mike um but do you see that patients
leave their prescriptions at pharmacies
because they can no longer pay for it
they absolutely do in my Pharmacy yes
that happens
um more than should make anyone come I
actually have a fun little story my
staff is probably going to talk to me
about this later but uh I left a
prescription at a pharmacy once
um I went to get birth control and
um I was there at the counter and went
to pay for it and the the price was very
very high I said wow is this a three six
month prescription no ma'am this is one
month and I said it's cheaper to have a
kid wow and I left it there and now I
have my third son Caden bobert um and so
I'm actually it was it was turned out to
be a really great thing but um I
personally experienced that when times
were tough but um thank you so much for
your Indulgence there and talk to the
team about that comment later oh my
team's gonna get me in trouble because I
told an insane story so there's a lot
here there's a there is a lot here
there's Lauren bobert's legislative
hypocrisy
there are the factual inaccuracies as
well so first and foremost Lauren Boberg
has been a staunch opponent of abortion
and Reproductive Rights she's voted
against expanding access to
contraception for millions of Americans
who need it and potentially are in the
position she was once in where paying
for the birth control is expensive so
she has been someone who if this story
is true
she understands how difficult it can be
and she has voted against making it
easier to access birth control for
millions of Americans she also seems
completely oblivious to the fact that
raising a kid is way more expensive than
paying completely out of pocket for the
birth control pills which with most
insurance plans now are actually free
anyway but forget about that for a
second
the research I've done suggests that out
of pocket
birth control is about 50 bucks a month
50 bucks a month the estimated cost of
raising a child to age 18 most recently
was 233 thousand dollars now that's a
six-year-old number inflation might make
it even higher at this point in time
that depends on a lot of different
things including uh standard of living
and geographical location all these
different things if you pay the 50 bucks
a month or six hundred dollars per year
for birth control out of pocket even
over 18 years if you were on out of
pocket birth control for 18 years that's
10 grand compared to at least 233
000 to raise a kid so what she's saying
is also very stupid and it actually
makes me wonder did she really believe
that is Lauren bobert so bad at either
math or or reality
that when she saw wow it's going to be
50 bucks for these birth control pills
did she really do some math that came
out with her thinking it's cheaper to
have a kid and to pay the costs of
having a kid for 18 years I don't know
it's a level of stupidity that really is
uh shocking and then there's the moral
aspect here as well she's essentially
saying I didn't even want this third kid
but I ended up having this third kid
because I had unprotected sex because I
couldn't afford the birth control and
therefore I didn't even actually want
this kid although she's saying he's a
good kid I like the kid it reminds me of
producer Lewis who once said if I
accidentally had a kid I'd probably love
the kid it seems like she ends up loving
her kid but she's saying essentially
that she didn't want that kid either
which I know is not uh there are many
parents who would have stories like this
but the funny little story that Lauren
bobert told is an extraordinarily
disturbing example of how out of touch
she is with the reality of what it costs
to raise a kid what it costs to pay for
birth control completely seemingly
morally disconnected
from what I would call a responsibility
that she has as a member of Congress to
okay you know of a problem that you
experienced you could vote to prevent
other people from having that very same
problem but she doesn't instead she
votes to make it more difficult to
access that very same thing truly and
absolutely disgusting and also seemingly
a clueless person